as quantum computers become more and
more powerful they have the potential to
completely reshape the cyber security
landscape so in this video we're going
to talk about what it means to become
Quantum safe and talk about terms like
Quantum safe cryptography
but before we dive into that let's first
take some time to do a quick recap on
classical cryptography
most of our modern encryption Protocols
are based on a combination of symmetric
and asymmetric encryption
so let's start by talking about
symmetric encryption
we're going to use a classic example of
Alice
who wants to send a secure message
to her friend Bob
in order to do this she first needs to
encrypt her message which she can do
using a secret key
she can then securely send her message
to Bob
who can then decrypt that message
using the same secret key
an asymmetric encryption Works in a very
similar way
but instead of Alice and Bob using the
same secret key
Alice will have a public key
and Bob will have a private key
so these keys are different one is
mathematically derived from the other
and in a nutshell
anyone could possibly access that public
key but only the private key can be used
to decrypt the message
and so most uh some most of our most
popular uh cryptographic algorithms
include examples such as RSA
diffie-hellman
and elliptic curve cryptography and
these are all asymmetric encryption
algorithms and they are based on three
different types of mathematical problems
namely
factorization
discrete logarithm
and elliptic curve discrete logarithm
and these uh cryptographic algorithms
work so well because these mathematical
problems that they're based on are very
difficult to solve but their Solutions
are very computationally easy to check
so for example if we wanted to crack RSA
we would need to factorize a
2048 bit
integer which serves as the public
key
using a classical computer this could
take potentially millions of years
but quantum computers are different
when quantum computers reach full
maturity they have the potential to
solve factorization and discrete
logarithm problems much much faster
so instead of relying on these classical
cryptographic algorithms that have
served us so well up until now we need
to start thinking about Quantum safe
cryptographic algorithms
Quantum safe algorithms are based on
mathematical problems that neither
classical nor quantum computers can
solve efficiently
they're normally based on geometric
problems rather than numerical ones like
these one example is a problem
mathematical problems that are based on
lattices
so let's have a quick review on lattices
lattices could be very simple like this
just a grid of points
with lines in between them that can
represent vectors
um and this is just a simple
two-dimensional lattice but lattices
could have many more dimensions
and they can also vary in size they
could be of of even an infinite
infinite size
and we can use a range of different
lattice based problems to develop a
Quantum safe cryptographic algorithms
one example is the
short
vector
problem
and the short Vector problem essentially
works like this let's say we have a very
small simple lattice like this
and we can draw some lines in between
them that represent the vectors between
each of the points
and the way that I've drawn it out here
is what is known as a short
basis
but I could draw this exact same lattice
in a slightly different way
and you can kind of see here how the
vectors in between each of the points
are much longer so we would call this a
long basis
so the short Vector problem is
essentially let's say we have a point in
the middle of this lattice here or if
it's we're representing it like this it
could look like that
um and to solve this problem we want to
find the closest points to a on this
lattice if we're given a short basis
this can be quite easy to see where the
shortest
um vectors are between between the
points but if we're only given a long
basis this becomes much more complicated
and you can imagine this problem would
get even more difficult if we increase
the size of the lattice and if we add
many more dimensions
and so this is quite a simple example
but it really highlights the the key
point of lattice based problems which is
that the larger and more complex the
lattice the more difficult it is to
solve math problems that are based on
them and the more difficult it would be
to crack algorithms that are based on
those problems
it might still be many years before
quantum computers can crack algorithms
like RSA but it also takes a really long
time for teams and organizations to
adopt and deploy new cryptographic
standards the National Institute for
standards and Technology says it can
take anywhere from 5 to 15 years to
implement new cryptographic standards
as you can imagine it takes time to
train developers and cyber Security
Professionals as well as implement the
new standards as well
but nist has actually been researching
different standards already since 2016
and in July of 2022 they identified four
different standards that organizations
can start looking into to become Quantum
State safe
and three of those were developed by IBM
they include
Crystal's dilithium
digital signature algorithm as well as
the Falcon digital signature algorithm
and lastly
the crystals
kyber
public key encryption algorithm and IBM
is already helping organizations become
Quantum safe in 2022 as well as these uh
announcing these cryptographic standards
from nist they also launched the first
Quantum safe system with the launch of
their Z16 platform
and they also offer the IBM Quantum safe
program which aims to educate and
provide strategic guidance towards
organizations that are looking to become
Quantum safe with individualized
programs to help organizations Better
understand their exposure to
cryptographic attacks
so if you and your team and your
organization are ready to start becoming
Quantum safe check out the links in the
description to all the things that I
mentioned in this video remember to like
subscribe leave any questions that you
have in the comments I hope you found
this content helpful and thank you very
much for watching